[Music]
artificial intelligence has already
become a part of our lives
and i wanted to learn more about it
the course is helping me tremendously in
my upskilling journey hi i'm daniel dick
i'm 66 years old and i'm semi-retired
and live in california with my wife and
son
since childhood i've had a strong
interest in science and technology i was
fascinated by the way systems worked
internally and how algorithms performed
but after 40 years of working in
technology sector i could no longer work
it hit me hard
i looked at how well my daughter was
doing as a software engineer my daughter
became my inspiration up skill
and over the years i pursued various
courses in different fields of computer
science
i realized that technology has the power
to change the world i worked rigorously
in the healthcare sector as a technocrat
and i know technology can revolutionize
it
i wanted to know how it could be used in
the healthcare sector and other sectors
so i can contribute to those domains
whenever i start something of my own
so i chose the aiml bootcamp from
simplylearn in association with caltech
ctme
the course is practical all the minute
details and concepts are explained in
the most simplistic manner
the curriculum was well designed
considering learners from different
backgrounds it was an amalgamation of
practical labs and theory
the program focuses on building a
problem-solving attitude
in learners the course is helping me
tremendously in my upskilling journey in
solving real
life problems whatever the problem is
you can either solve it or learn to
solve it by upskilling yourself
[Music]